[Music]
on this Friday night an overwhelmed
police force an ex-ottawa police chief
testifies about his handling of the
so-called Freedom Convoy it was crushing
to the members morale the emotional
testimony in defense of his actions
inching towards sovereignty we couldn't
sit back and keep waiting for the
government what won First Nations push
for representation could mean for
communities across the country plus
billionaire takeover the changes already
Rippling through Twitter as the world's
richest man takes the reins and where is
Nancy the disturbing detail emerging of
a violent break-in at the home of one of
America's top politicians
[Music]
global national with Farah Nasser
reporting tonight nipu gotcha good
evening and thanks for joining us the
former Chief of the Ottawa Police
Service was in the hot seat today at the
inquiry into the government's use of the
emergencies act to break up the
so-called Freedom Convoy protests in
downtown Ottawa in February Peter slowly
who resigned just one day after the Act
was invoked got emotional as he
testified the protest was overwhelming
his Force while his officers were doing
their best to peacefully end the
occupation
they were doing their very best
under inhuman circumstances like the
city was like the community was
it was too cold and it was too much
slowly testified that even with the
benefit of hindsight nothing in
intelligence reports before the convoys
arrival indicated to him they would stay
past the weekend slowly also testified
he believes the demonstration became
unlawful on the first Saturday morning
of the occupation when he saw protesters
digging in and fortifying their
positions Eric Sorensen has the details
even as Convoy protesters began arriving
that Thursday and Friday in January
ottawa's then chief of police believe
they would leave soon enough OPP
intelligence had warned the protesters
could stay and by Saturday some were
clearly setting up for a longer
occupation but former Chief Peter slowly
said the briefings he had did not change
his view this was going to be a Thursday
Friday mainly Saturday Sunday event with
the potential for a smaller group to
remain behind
by Monday it was clear a large number of
demonstrators had no intention of going
anywhere the Ottawa Police said slowly
were overwhelmed and as the police
largely stood by making no arrests they
were roundly criticized the level of
disinformation and misinformation was
off the charts
it was crushing to the members morale by
midweek frustration was mounting as life
in downtown Ottawa was being disrupted
with no end in sight and at that moment
slowly said this there is likely no
policing Solutions he explained today
that he meant not just a policing
solution but the need for governments
and other agencies to work together but
Rumblings were beginning about slowly's
leadership from the RCMP commissioner
notes that the inquiry showed Brenda
Luckey believed the federal government
was losing confidence in slowly and one
of slowly's own deputies suggested
Ottawa Police didn't appreciate what was
brewing I think there was definitely a
failure to appreciate one lesson learned
is the need for greater integration of
intelligence across all agencies to be
better prepared in policing you plan for
the worst and hope for the best and I
think probably what backfired is uh
it happened in Reverse bad things
happened and not good things there was
internal confusion within the Ottawa
Police and among the different forces on
February 14th the federal government
invoked the emergencies act giving
police greater powers to clear the
protesters but it had all taken a toll
on slowly who stepped down one day later
it was clear to me that the trust factor
in Ottawa Police Service was still
headed in the wrong direction
and the only person that could take that
pressure off the Ottawa Police Service
was me and I made that decision to
resign from office the big question at
the inquiry remains was the emergencies
act necessary the commission will
consider what factors prompted that
decision and whether one of them was an
overwhelmed Ottawa Police Department
Eric Sorensen Global News
the pandemic pushed people online more
than ever before and as a result the
number of sophisticated cyber threats is
at an all-time high in its newly
released assessment the Canadian Center
for cyber security is outlining the top
online dangers they involve some large
targets but as Dan Spector reports the
average person could also get hit at any
time
so the report is not meant to be
anything uh scary but the online world
seems to be getting spookier by the day
in this new report intelligence
officials say the biggest issue facing
Canadians connected to the internet in
2022 is the endless amount of scammers
trying to steal your money watching
where you click has never been so
important it's becoming more and more
sophisticated and often uh it is through
a phishing email but there are much
larger targets than your bank account
the cyber security Center says critical
infrastructure faces growing risks take
the example of Toronto's Humber River
Hospital being paralyzed last year by a
ransomware attack Essential Health
Services halted my advice the Prime
Minister repeat would really be around
critical infrastructure because I do
think that's where we're seeing a lot of
legislative movement right now then
there are the growing activities of
foreign actors Russia China North Korea
Iran among the Nations already running
state-sponsored cyber operations against
Canada this expert feels the newest
assessment underplays the Russian threat
so I think that the CSC report while you
know it hits the the mark on on several
issues uh it really misses the mark uh
quite extraordinarily on on their
assessment of Russian disinformation and
influence operations targeting Canada
misinformation and disinformation
hitting our eyes daily spreading
falsehoods about the war in Ukraine or
events unfolding here at home you know
that Russian State media was
legitimizing uh Fringe actors within the
the freedom Convoy protest movements the
government points to ongoing efforts to
bolster cyber security including nearly
a billion dollars in the most recent
budget what is the role of government
should we have online hate legislation
or something else you'll be empowering
the RCMP to to take action or should we
be imposing heightened requirements on
social media platforms themselves
Parsons only hopes that as the
government widens the online fight it
does so legally and without infringing
on your privacy Dan Specter Global News
the deal is done Elon Musk has purchased
Twitter and immediately made his Mark by
firing senior Executives he calls
himself a free speech absolutist and
their speculation musk may allow bad
users including Donald Trump back on the
social media platform but as Redmond
Shannon reports musk is also trying to
reassure mainstream investors
it can now really sink in the world's
richest person Elon Musk owns Twitter he
bought it for a staggering 44 billion US
Dollars despite his efforts in the
spring to get out of the deal musk is
overpaying by double that's why it's
going to go down as a head scratcher but
it's a deal he couldn't get out of musk
will want to claw back some of that cash
the Canadian citizen says he wants to
make it an everything app perhaps with a
subscription fee shopping and payments
but he also wants to see it let loose as
a platform for free speech tweeting the
bird is freed which is making
advertisers nervous as well
um it's yet to be seen how he's going to
square that sir mosque says he will be
forming a Content moderation Council to
decide on reinstating banned users one
of the executives just fired by musk was
reportedly Central to banning Donald
Trump on Trump's own social media media
platform the former U.S president
welcomed musk's deal saying he is happy
that Twitter is now in sane hands and
will no longer be run by radical left
lunatics musk says he wants to make
Twitter a Town Square for the left and
the right but not a free-for-all
hellscape some media analysts say it's
never ideal when the super rich control
communication the free speech of a
Billionaire's friends remains Paramount
while the freedom of expression and
speech of those who are questioning or
critical is very very liable to be
curtailed musk has been criticized for
his views on issues like Russia's
invasion of Ukraine and the covid-19
pandemic now that Twitter is his nest
the billionaire will be able to chirp
louder than ever Redmond Shannon Global
News London
the House of Commons is now recognizing
the residential school system as an act
of genocide after a Winnipeg MP's motion
passed with unanimous consent on the
third try
we need to do better we need to find a
way forward that honors the truth about
what happened in this country especially
in light of Pope francis's
acknowledgment that what took place in
residential schools was in fact genocide
after question period Leah gazan said
she was grateful parliamentarians are
now recognizing the truth of Canada's
history this type of motion doesn't
always reflect official government
policies but instead reflects the will
of the House of Commons they pass if no
other MPS voice opposition when the
motion is moved
residential school survivors and their
families looking for help can call the
residential school survivors and family
crisis line at 1-800-721-0066
a first nation in Alberta is taking what
it believes will be a precedent setting
step towards indigenous sovereignty and
Reconciliation within Canada's justice
system nation has hired a law firm to
create the country's first ever First
Nation bylaw prosecutor's office as
Heather York's West reports lawyers will
represent the nation instead of the
crown in court in order to enforce local
band Council resolutions and bylaws when
we talk about our Justice Lindsey
mincher and Andrew Coleman are not
members of the Sika First Nation the
Calgary lawyers are both non-indigenous
but the two will soon be spending a lot
of time in this community as newly
appointed prosecutors not for the crown
but for the sick of First Nation itself
we're going to start building an office
that allows them to prosecute their own
bylaws because historically those have
fallen by the word they've not been
prosecuted by the federal government
they're not being prosecuted by the
provincial government sodomly and
sincerely it sounds like a novel concept
because in Canada it is under the Indian
Act First Nation councils can create ban
resolutions or bylaws to govern their
communities but these rules are often
not enforced by police agencies or the
courts if you have buy less that you can
enforce and put onto the books then why
isn't there someone to prosecute that
that's a huge piece of the puzzle that
is just not there
accounts for Samuel Crowfoot is a lawyer
and served as the chief judge for a
tribal court in New Mexico he believes
First Nations across Canada can learn a
lot from how things have been done in
indigenous communities South of the
Border the sixth first nation is not the
only indigenous community seeking this
change in the days following the mass
killings on the James Smith Cree Nation
in Saskatchewan Community leaders there
made a similar call our bylaws
our band Council resolutions
they have to be
enforced by the RCMP
they have to be we couldn't sit back and
keep waiting for the government
you know we had to take steps in our own
hands the cyclical First Nation and
their new prosecutors know there will be
challenges ahead as they Forge an
Uncharted path with Canada's courts but
the team says it's ready to get to work
not only for the community here but has
set important legal precedence for other
indigenous communities across the
country thank you heather urich's West
Global News Calgary
we were giving terms of this ain't the
right time
when will be the right time for
indigenous peoples to be at the
Forefront in this so-called Spirit of
reconciliation
leaders behind what would have been the
Olympics led by an indigenous group
reacting after the bid for Vancouver
2030 came to a grinding halt the
provincial government has chosen not to
support it citing cost those involved
with the bids say they're disheartened
by the lack of consultation
a violent break-in at Nancy Pelosi's
house coming up the investigation into
the attack that sent Pelosi's husband to
hospital
a man in San Francisco was facing
charges in connection with a violent
assault on house Speaker Nancy Pelosi's
husband Paul Pelosi was attacked early
this morning in his California home his
wife was in Washington at the time
police are saying little about the
motive but some details are emerging
about the suspect Jackson prosco is
following the latest developments
Jackson what more can you tell us
well neither this happened just after 2
A.M local time in San Francisco video
clearly shows the smashed windows at the
back door of the Pelosi home and police
say when they arrive they saw the
suspect and Paul Pelosi struggling over
a hammer they say Mr Pelosi was then
violently struck before the suspect was
tackled by officers here's perhaps the
truly concerning part reports suggest
that after the suspect entered the home
he began asking where's Nancy where's
Nancy and that's the exact same kind of
language used by some of the January 6th
rioters who stormed Pelosi's office
inside the Capitol building now the
suspect is identified as 42-year-old
David depape the charges he faces
include attempted homicide his online
posts are filled with right-wing
conspiracy theories about the 2020
election about January 6 and about covid
vaccines we've seen politicians from
both parties rush to condemn this attack
but make no mistake there is increasing
fear about political violence in this
country especially with midterm
elections just 11 days away and with the
rhetoric still so heated polls suggest a
majority of both Democrats and
Republicans now view the other party as
an existential threat to the nation as
for Paul Pelosi he's in hospital
expected to survive though his injuries
are considered serious in a statement
tonight speaker Pelosi is asking for
privacy for her family nithu all right
Jackson prosco in Washington thanks
Jackson
the music world is saying farewell to
one of rock and roll's biggest
Trailblazers Jerry Lee Lewis has passed
away
multiply
[Music]
known by his nickname the killer Lewis
was one of the first rock and roll Stars
performing alongside icons like Elvis
Presley and Johnny Cash he was a major
influence on generations of musicians
but he also gained notoriety for his
struggles with substance abuse and a
slew of scandals that included a secret
marriage to a 13 year old girl Lewis was
87.
pregnancy loss support ahead confusion
and concerns around access to leave
across Canada
a topic that's traditionally only been
talked about in private is starting to
have more public attention recognition
and less stigma as we told you last week
bereavement and support Provisions for
those who've suffered pregnancy loss are
slowly improving at least in some
provinces but Advocates say there's
still a lack of awareness and a lot of
confusion here's Ross Lord
pregnancy loss is still largely a taboo
subject no one knows better than Nova
Scotia researcher Stephanie Gilbert she
lost a baby at 37 weeks there's very
little support out there and there's
very little access to the information
especially when it comes to Lost leave
options
so there's a lot of confusion especially
right after your loss around like what
time can I have what am I eligible for
and so on I was able to take 15 weeks
off and really felt ready to go back to
work after the 15 weeks and I'm learning
now through conversations with many
other pregnancy loss sufferers is that I
seem to be an exception Gilbert has
interviewed dozens of other women who
experienced pregnancy loss among the 3
000 fetal deaths that happen every year
in Canada and very few of those people
were even aware that there are paid
leave options for them most resort to
taking sick time vacation days or
rushing back to their jobs there's a
hodgepodge of bereavement leave policies
across Canada many provinces or
territories using a broad definition
including time off for the loss of most
family members or an immediate family
member but they don't specify options
for pregnancy loss Pei does include
pregnancy loss along with Nova scotia's
newly changed legislation it's named
Ruby law after this liberal mla's
granddaughter born still at 32 weeks
they will know what each member here did
and it will help them he
my family heal many provinces do offer
pregnancy leaves separately either with
or without pay but for those with enough
hours of work to qualify Federal
maternity benefits are sometimes a
better option and that's paid time you
get up to a maximum of 55 percent of
your salary through that program for 15
weeks and so that's quite generous for
people who don't have a loss after 20
weeks so that maybe it's then it's
considered a miscarriage if it's prior
to 20 weeks then you can qualify for
sickness leave benefits through
employment insurance with growing
awareness Gilbert and other Advocates
hope this scatter shot system of leave
Provisions will soon be made more
accessible and less confusing for those
who've endured a trauma so difficult to
discuss
Ross Lord Global News Halifax
[Music]
[Music]
when you're purchasing an item how do
you pay if cash wasn't your first answer
you're not alone in fact Canada is one
of the leading countries in the world
going cashless due to the convenience
and how much faster it is for the new
reality senior business reporter Anne
gaviola looked into the trend and
as a form of payment Canadians are
moving away from cash opting for debit
credit mobile wallets and smart watches
speed ease and convenience are driving
Canadians to choose plastic over cash
but that's not all Canadians also have a
history with technology that's helped
push contactless and digital forms of
payment to the Forefront including the
early adoption of automated banking
machines and the interbank transaction
system interact experts say those
digital advancements have greatly
influenced our Behavior I don't know if
we often pause to think how strange it
is to just pause in the middle of the
street
pay a bill on your phone while
monitoring your Investments these are
both characteristically modern
experiences but also very peculiar so
how quickly are we moving away from cash
a Global Payments report is projecting
that by 2025 cash will only make up
three percent of all point-of-sale
transactions in the country
so even though paying with cash is on a
steady decline across the country
Canadians still find cash comforting for
example during times of Crisis there
tends to be an uptick in cash
withdrawals because it offers people a
sense of comfort and security and during
the pandemic an RBC report has shown a
spike in people withdrawing cash and
using it as a vehicle to stash and some
businesses are also still dedicated to
cash only and its benefits when people
want to use a card to pay with like one
of those serious or debit or Square
systems that costs the business money so
every time you go to a restaurant and
pay with your card that business is
losing money
so cash hasn't lost its appeal but its
role in an increasingly cashless culture
is unknown
and you can catch Anne's full story on
the new reality tomorrow at 7 pm right
here on global and that is global
national for this Friday we leave you
tonight with an art World blunder that
went unnoticed for nearly 80 years for
77 years Piet montreon's New York City
one has been hanging upside down in a
German Gallery the error was realized
after pictures were found from 1944 but
it's going to stay upside down at least
for now there are concerns that if it's
flipped it could fall apart I'm Nito
Garcia thanks for watching far Nasser
will be here tomorrow
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]